now in act 4 we often have a beginning
we often have to store lines together
the a and the D this is often true and
it's true in this story the a story line
remember is will won't become a badass
drug dealer and look at that
when we watch him and act for he's
hustling equipment out of his high
school he's become a thief beakers
synthetic stuff everything now we also
are watching the D story because Jesse
is reluctantly becoming the the
Sorcerer's Apprentice right that's
exactly the relationship they're gonna
have for the next seven years Jesse and
Walter becoming co-conspirators and
they're also we're also seeing Walt's
genius remember superpowers being
misused at the beginning of the show
when he's beginning to use it
he's begin to use this chemical genius
again we're gonna make a product that is
synthetically pure it's gonna be perfect
and Jesse's like now I want to make
chili Chili's my spec chili P is my
trademark we're gonna put chili in it we
are gonna make a synthetic product that
is perfect Jesse shut up
so this reluctant relationship really
was gonna go on for seven years the D
storyline will Walt ingest and become
colleagues is gonna resonate through the
entire seven years they'll fall apart
that come back together but at the very
last episode of this show they are still
co-conspirators right to the end the
other thing you're gonna see in act 4 is
this the most amazing use of the
suspense tools you've ever seen good
news bad news ticking clocks raising
stakes they are used brilliantly by
Gilligan it's part of the reason some
people can't watch this show for more
than 10 minutes they after I literally
turn it off and then cool down and watch
it again because the suspense is
agonizingly good and you're gonna see
all that in act 4 the other thing you're
gonna see an act for is that remember in
a movie there is what I call a BMOC the
four times in a movie when the hero is
asked to change in a television show the
heroes asked to change too but he
doesn't much and the sense there's a
five acts there's a B M MOC for more
information on this structure go to
university of story look at my
foundations lecture my TV lecture this
is a pattern that great television shows
have
at four you're going to see both the Oh
point the obstacle point the moment when
it looks like all is lost and you're
also gonna see the climax of the
television show where the hero wins both
of these points are present in one act
that's the brilliance of using a
structure of the ABCDE storyline I know
it sounds prissy and mathematical but
it's actually a beautiful way to tell an
original story and make it entertaining
you can tell any story you want you can
tell a story about two skunks two
bisexual skunks it doesn't matter if you
use these tools actually I don't think
about sexual skunks where you'd work
that well but all right so anyway they
get a used Winnebago with all the money
just that Walter has in the world but
when Walter gets out of the credit union
with the cash and gives it to Jesse
Jesse system hey listen I got a known
just for my own because what you do
affects me what you do affects me have
you just gone nuts it doesn't compute
why does a guy I don't know 60 years old
well says 50 how does the six year old
guy suddenly just break bad I mean have
you gone crazy this affects me and
Walter finally says the critical thing
about his core wound remember his core
wound is that I'm powerless
that's his core wound and he says to
Jesse the truth right here he says I am
he's finally feeling powerful that's the
critical thing to realize about Walter
it is also his unsolvable dilemma
remember we talked about what that was
at the beginning of this lecture
his unsolvable dilemma is that he wants
to take care of his family but the way
he's doing it is destroying his family
that is unresolvable it will never be
resolved not for seven years so Jesse
goes and gets the Winnebago we're still
in Act four they drive out to the desert
and they begin to make this meth
now most stories have what I call speed
and weed in a romantic comedy the weed
is real estate and alpha males and and
building shoe closets and having
a guy who can communicate and be
sensitive as well as powerful and strong
it's the pleasure you get from a story
in this story because the hook is how
bad will Walter go and the premises he's
gonna make drugs the weed and speed
literally is weed and speed as they make
this drug the music mounts watch this
scene guys you'll get caught up with it
it's the sorcerer and his assistant as
they cook this perfect meth and the
music swells and Jesse screws up and
Walter saves them and at the end there
is a pan of beautiful sky blue
methamphetamine that is the purest meth
ever made in the world and when it's
finished you're the goddamn Iron Chef
you're amazing and Walter says it's just
basic chemistry but thank you Jesse
he is using his genius for chemistry and
he is becoming a powerful guy still an
app for Walter says to Jesse how do we
sell this and Jesse says I know just the
guy to take it - and this is where the e
plot kicks in because the guy who was
busted in the second act
crazy me Emilio and krazy-8 we cut to
Jesse walking up to their house a
barking dog that's attacking a dummy and
we start to get danger rising because
when Jesse tries to sell this drug to
crazy eight crazy eight says hey where
did you get this I know you didn't I
knew your little dumb ass didn't cook it
where'd you get this take me to this guy
we're approaching the all is lost moment
of the show because as their lowrider
neon yellow gangster car pulls up to the
Winnebago where Walter is standing in
his underwear with nobody for miles the
two gangsters pull their guns and they
prepare to kill Walter and Jesse that is
the low point for Walter now remember
why does this super power how are we
gonna see it and remember what support
what's replaces care
to change in television surprise because
as they prepare to kill them both
ticking clocks guns Walter says wait a
minute I'll teach you my recipe you'll
let us live and I'll teach you how to
cook and the villains say okay now
Walter hasn't been saved it's only a
temporary reprieve but as he goes into
the RV with both guys guns pointed at
his head ticking clocks the gun when
will the guns go off the music begins to
give us a literal ticking clock sound
tick tock tick tock and as we watch
Walter create more methamphetamine we
see him pick up a bottle that we've been
explained is poison if it's subjected to
heat and it's the clocks tick and one of
the villains throws a cigarette out the
window that's another ticking clock we
have four simultaneous to make clocks on
the scene watch it it's fabulous
suddenly Walter throws the red
phosphorus into the fire boom and a
poison blows up in the cloud and the two
gangsters begin to die
Walter jumps out of the RV slams the
door behind him good news bad news they
fire through the door but then they die
Walt is winning the a storyline will
become a badass drug dealer yes
we'll just seen him work together yes II
story line with Walt and Jesse win over
crazy and Emilio yes but it could end
here but it doesn't why because we need
more tension and suspense suddenly that
cigarette that was thrown out the window
catches fire and the entire place starts
to burn Walt has to escape he gets in
the RV as the music swells he and Jesse
roll through the desert with those two
bodies in the back and guess what we're
back at the cold open remember with the
RV running through the desert Walt
stopping getting out the two bodies in
the back he makes the video confession
he goes to the road he's got the gun
pointed and now that's where we are and
now we see that siren ticking clock get
louder and louder the cops are coming
Walt's gonna lose everything's over for
him then good news
that turns out not to be cops but the
firemen and they don't care about Walt
at all they go by flipping his underwear
up and down and he through sheer amazing
genius and luck has won the firemen
leave they've killed the two guys Walt
has answered the a storyline question
will you be a badass regular hell yes
and I've become a murderer too and then
he vomits because remember he's still a
weak guy so in our resolution we finally
wrap up the final storyline witches will
Walt take care of his family we see him
laundering literally the money that he's
made he's taking care of his family
financially and this time when he and
Scarlett go to have sex she suddenly
gasps because Walter is that you he can
suddenly be a man there too so the story
ends with this B storyline answered yes
with the a storyline answered yes with
the c-store Lana answered yes every
story than answered yes Walt has become
a badass drug dealer and a murderer and
we're gonna watch him go further with
that for the next seven years this is
brilliant television because we've set
up a hook that we want to watch another
hundred episodes to see and it's a
classic classic thriller and guys
television is thirsty for thrillers
there are 400 scripted stories now who
need stories please use the tools I've
given you tonight not only in thrillers
but for every television genre because
they work across the board
you